else's hands have ice powers Rapunzel's
hair has healing powers and mallanna has
the power over the ocean but what about
the other Disney Princesses keep
watching to the end to discover all the
clues in the frozen two trailer about
honest possible secret power here's our
take on what magic powers each of the
Disney Princesses should have Harry
Potter eat your heart out
[Music]
Ariel we're starting off with Ariel and
a magic power we think she might already
possess did you ever wonder why Eric was
so enchanted by Ariel's voice sure it's
lovely but he was totally obsessed with
it so obsessed in fact that he was
willing to marry Vanessa because she had
Ariel's voice to understand the possible
reason for Eric's enchantment we have to
turn to old legends about merfolk
specifically the sirens these magical
creatures existed in greek mythology as
dangerous mermaid like beings they lured
sailors with their enchanting singing
voices leading them to shipwreck on the
rocks of their Island we see the power
of the sirens song again in free forms
mermaid mystery thriller TV series
called sirens in this show the sirens
have a unique voice box which is
described as being almost supernatural
they can lure others towards themselves
with their song that has dark
consequences just like the original
sirens of mythology we think the star of
the Little Mermaid might just have this
enchanted voice - we're definitely not
suggesting Ariel would use her magic
power for destruction but we think it
makes perfect sense for Ariel to have a
magic power that lies in her voice she
could use it to enchance people to do
what she wants but only for good things
or she could use her voice to control
the ocean but in a very different way
than Mohana can our next princess also
has a magic power that is hinted at in
her movie
snow white snow white loves animals it's
not surprising given that the forest
animals are her only friends until she
meets the dwarfs in Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs it actually seems like Snow
White can speak to the animals well she
certainly talks a lot to them anyway and
they seem to understand her
they lead her to the dwarfs cottage when
she's looking for a safe place to stay
squirrels deer and the turtle help her
clean doves rabbits chipmunks and
raccoons gather around her she even
sings a duet with a baby bird so we
think Snow White might already have the
magic power of being able to talk to
animals just like dr. Dolittle we can
tell it's not the case that everyone in
Snow White's world can talk to animals
when the animals try to let the door of
snow that Snow White is in trouble
the dwarfs don't understand them so it
seems like it's just Snow White's
special power the question is what could
she use the magical gift for we think it
would be fun for Snow White to be the
Disney Princesses official animal
interpreter after all lots of the
princesses have animal sidekicks and
Friends Snow White could translate and
help everyone understand each other
Cinderella for our next princess we're
looking at a sequel movie for a clue as
to what her magic power could be
Cinderella's third movie called
Cinderella 3 a twist and time is all
about controlling time when the fairy
godmother loses her one lady tremaine
uses it to reverse time the action goes
back to before Cinderella tried on the
slipper magic makes the slipper fit
Anastasia's foot instead and they use
the wand to wipe the Prince Charming's
memory suffice to say it all works out
fine in the end but that story got us
thinking that Cinderella would be
totally suited to having magical powers
over time after all time plays an
important part in her story she only has
until midnight until the fairy
godmothers transformations end and she
has to race against time to try on the
glass slipper so if Cinderella has the
magic power of controlling time what
could she do with it
well she could pause time whenever she
needed to get ready for a ball or if she
lost another shoe she could go back in
time and find
Bell when you think of bells favorite
things what do you picture the Beast of
course but also books when we first meet
our heroine in Beauty and the Beast
she's all about her books and also about
wanting more than her provincial life so
we think Belle would love having the
magic power of SuperSpeed there are a
couple of ways she'd totally owned this
power first off she could read her books
really quickly that means she could read
even more of them she'd get through
beasts library in no time we've seen
what that power looks like already in
the Disney Universe in descendants - we
see mal used the speed reading spell to
help her read a book in record speed
Belle would certainly put that power to
good use we think she could also use it
to have even more adventures she sings
about wanting adventure in the Great
Wide somewhere so if she had the magic
power of SuperSpeed she could have even
more adventures by traveling really
quickly across the great wide world
Aurora did you know that Aurora is the
only Disney Princess to have violet eyes
and it's her unusual eyes that we think
would be the source of her magic power
we reckon Aurora should have the power
to send people into a trance
just by looking into their eyes how did
we come up with that it's all down to
the events in her movie in Sleeping
Beauty Aurora is cursed to fall asleep
when she pricks her finger on a spinning
wheel so wouldn't it be totally amazing
if she took on that curse and managed to
harness its power within her and our own
version of a Sleeping Beauty sequel
we've learned that when Maleficent's
curse took effect it went deep inside
Aurora sure she was awoken from her
slumber by true love's kiss but part of
the power of the curse remains within
her instead of being used against her
however the curse became Aurora's power
with the power of her gaze she became
able to send others into a trance-like
sleep
watch out Maleficent we can easily
picture how freaky Aurora's eyes would
look when she's using her power all you
have to do is watch the scene when she's
hypnotized walking toward the spinning
wheel creepy jasmine
when you think about all the magical
powers you might like to have what's up
there as the best we reckon the ability
to fly would be an amazing power to have
it would make you feel like a fairy or a
bird or even a magical flying carpet to
magic carpet that's why we think Jasmine
should have the magic power of flight
because she looked totally at home
soaring through the air on the magic
carpet with Aladdin
in fact jasmine looked like a natural
what could Jasmine use her magic power
for well there's definitely a touch of
the rebel about jasmine she defies her
father unknowingly steals an apple from
the market and runs away from home so we
reckoned Jasmine could have quite a lot
of fun with this power she could hang
out with Tinkerbell and the other Disney
Fairies getting up to mischief Merida
levitation is another magical power that
would be high on our list just imagine
being able to make things rise and float
in midair we reckon Merida would be
right at home with this power after all
she manages to make arrows float through
the air with total precision we see in
her movie brave but Merida is already
the best archer in all the land she
beats the sons of the other leaders
easily but just imagine how formidable
she'd be if she had the power of
levitation at her fingertips she could
stop her competitors arrows in
mid-flight and make them float of course
levitation is one of the spells that the
students of Hogwarts learn in Harry
Potter
wouldn't it be cool if Merida used her
bow or arrow as her wand all she'd have
to do is point at an object say the
secret spell and voila hovering flying
objects at her command
Mulan just like Merida Mulan has pretty
formidable skills already but you know
what would make her an even more
successful fighter if she had the magic
power of invisibility this is another
power we see in Harry Potter but the
witches and wizards that can't earn
themselves invisible don't do so through
spells they have to use a physical
object an invisibility cloak Harry's dad
James Potter used one when he was a
student at Hogwarts to help him
get up to mischief but we think moulin
would use the magic power of
invisibility for more serious tasks she
could use her magic power to sneak up on
her enemies when they're having meetings
so she could discover their plans she
could also use it in battle as well if
she had the power to turn herself
invisible cut bulan also have the power
to turn others invisible - if so she
definitely let's Shang in on the action
as an invisible team they'd be
unbeatable enemies that are watch out
tiana we can't help but think of Harry
Potter when we think of magic powers and
this next one is also something that
we'd see at Hogwarts one of Tiana's
biggest challenges in The Princess and
the Frog was becoming human again after
she turned into a frog so she knows a
thing or two about Transfiguration in
Harry Potter they described
Transfiguration as the alteration of the
form or appearance of an object person
or animal it's regarded as very hard
work in the Wizarding World that's no
problem for Tiana though she's surely
the hardest worker out of all the Disney
Princesses she's the only one that has a
job in fact she works two jobs so how
would her transfigurations skills work
we reckon Siana would use potions rather
than a wand to turn people into animals
she's such a great cook that she'd have
no trouble creating potions out of
various ingredients Pocahontas
Pocahontas is one of the princesses
that's most in touch with nature when we
watch her running leaping and dancing'
as she sings her colors of the wind song
it's almost like she has magical powers
already she can store high and run fast
she's so in touch with the natural world
around her that it makes sense that her
magic power would revolve around nature
too Pocahontas is also able to
communicate with grandmother willow
so we think her power would be related
to nature spirit guides - in Harry
Potter the Patronus is a similar idea
it's described as a guardian which acts
as a shield between a person and a
Dementor it's also called a positive
force and a projection of hope and
happiness
Harry's Patronus takes the form of a
stag just like his dad's there's
something about these smoke like vapor
shapes that resonate with Pocahontas -
she could have the magic power of
conjuring spirit guides and seeing other
people's guides - Anna we already know
that anna has the super power of love
and frozen's she saved Elsa from Hans
with her sisterly love but we reckon she
might have another magic power which
will be revealed and frozen to the
trailer for the sequel has got everyone
so intrigued with theories about every
aspect of it when thinking about Ana's
powers is the heart-shaped purple fire
that has got us most intrigued it makes
total sense that Anna would have a
secret power after all Elsa was born
with ice power so surely her sister
could have a magic power - and what's
the opposite of ice fire that's what we
reckon Anna made that purple fire
surrounding Elsa and Olaf if Anna had a
fire power then the two sisters would
balance each other out it's like winter
versus summer but why hasn't Anna used
her powers yet there's a theory behind
that when Elsa hits Anna with her icy
powers as a child
grand pabbie troll healed Anna by
removing all traces of magic including
her memories perhaps Ana's magic fire
power has been lying dormant all this
time we can't wait to see if that theory
comes true in frozen - so there you have
it our take on the magic powers the
Disney Princesses should have which
magic power would you give to your
favorite princess let us know in the
comments section below thanks for
watching make sure to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one
we'll see you next time
[Music]